hey this is presh showwalker if you've
ever donated to a charity with a credit
card you may have seen an option to add
a certain amount to cover the credit
card transaction fees so the charity
gets the intended donation amount
I was thinking about this mathematically
and it's a little bit more complicated
than it seems at first
so imagine you wanted to give a gift of
a hundred dollars to a charity
suppose the credit card charges 25 cents
plus three percent
the fee on this gift will be 0.25 plus
three percent of a hundred dollars which
equals
3.25 cents
so you might wonder how much should they
add to the original gift so that they
net a hundred dollars you might think
they should just take the gift and then
add in the fee of 3.25 so if they charge
a hundred and three dollars and twenty
five cents will the charity actually net
one hundred dollars the answer is no so
let's see why
the new fees will be 25 cents plus three
percent of 103.25 which equals three
dollars and 35 cents subtracting that
from
103.25 will lead a net amount received
of
99.90 and this is 10 cents less than a
hundred dollars
so I know it's a small amount but the
entire purpose is to actually get the
entire intended gift
so how are we supposed to do this the
correct way
so let's set this up let's say G is the
gift amount f are the fees and C is the
charge
so the gift will be equal to the charge
minus the fees and the fees are equal to
0.25 plus 0.03 times C so we can
substitute in for f so G is equal to C
minus the quantity 0.25 plus 0.03 times
C
now we have G is equal to C multiplied
by 1 minus 0.03 minus 0.25 so we can
solve this equation for C to get that c
is equal to g plus 0.25 all over 1 minus
0.03 you of course want to round this up
to the nearest cent because when they
charge the fees they're going to round
up on the fees so let's see how this
works out
the gift is equal to one hundred dollars
so the amount you want to charge will be
100 plus 0.25 divided by 1 minus 0.03
and that works out to be
103.36 and that's the correct amount to
charge we can even generalize this let's
suppose we have a fixed swipe fee of s
and we need to add a percentage P so the
formula would then become G Plus s all
over 1 minus P percent and that's the
amount you should charge round it up to
the nearest cent
so even in something as simple as
covering transaction fees we lead to
some interesting mathematics but as a
practical matter many Charities will
just add four to five percent to cover
the transaction fees they don't want to
go through this messy calculation
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
thank you